hello my friends it's Clements here with
your PS Plus lineup for December 2016
this month we have invisible in console
edition on ps4 and stories the paths of
destinies the abyss bowling console
Edition combines turn-based strategy
with the world of espionage break into
the most dangerous corporations around a
new stealth technology and teamwork to
accomplish your goals and if you're
anything like me don't trip over
something on the way out that seriously
always happens next up on the list
stories the paths of destinies on ps4
guide the heroic reynardo through a
world that's always changing where your
choices affect reynardo fate and the
lives of those around them
Flicka to choose your own adventure book
wasn't a book at all but a video game I
think I've made my point here and that's
it friends as always PS Plus members get
access to online multiplayer on ps4
alongside other benefits including free
games and exclusive discounts on
PlayStation Store head on over to
PlayStation Blog for more details and
we'll see you next year